para la unión europea la meta está clara
nuestro objetivo es reducir los costos
del gas y por lo tanto propondremos un
precio tope para el gas ruso con las gas
así que aquí el objetivo es que debemos
recortar los ingresos de rusia que putin
utiliza para financiar su atroz guerra
en ucrania putin tampoco titubea en un
foro económico en vladivostok advirtió
que no cumplirán los contratos de
hidrocarburos si se les impone un techo
al precio del petróleo y el gas ruso
alguien va a tomar algún tipo de
decisión política que vaya en contra de
los contratos
simplemente no cumpliremos los contratos
no suministraremos nada si va en contra
de nuestros intereses económicos no
suministraremos gas petróleo carbón o
gas para la calefacción
la guerra discursiva entre bruselas y
moscú por la compraventa de gas y
petróleo solo aumenta sus decibelios el
grupo comunitario acusa a rusia de estar
utilizando la energía como arma de
guerra y asegura que las sanciones están
dañando la economía rusa que se mantiene
a flote por los combustibles putin niega
esta versión y culpa justamente a los
castigos internacionales por el cierre
indefinido del gasoducto nord stream el
juego político se da ahora en quién de
los dos actores dará ante su brazo a
torcer y no está claro quién va ganando
rusia vende gas o petróleo con
descuentos a actores fuera de la esfera
europea para que después de esos países
se vendan europa el gas y el petróleo
mucho más caro es decir hay tres actores
hay dos que ganan seguro y la europa
siempre pierde por lo tanto hoy tiene un
margen para permitirse hacer ese cálculo
de poder tampoco se sabe qué mecanismo
utilizaría el bloque europeo para
imponer límites a los precios pero lo
cierto es que el invierno dictará
sentencia en el 'viejo continente' que
impone restricciones planea recortes y
proyecta cambios para estrategia
energética